[Music]
we have a very special guest before we
go around the horn and look at all the
games we have we have we've been
speaking about a lot over the last
couple weeks the creator of the six
field chess tables we have Nate Cohen
with Murray's those beautiful tables you
see the players playing on right now is
because of this man Nate Cohen and guess
what it's his birthday today happy
birthday dude thank you my neck of the
woods you get a lot of punches it's
right there yeah you going to Brooklyn
well Nate you have been a part of this
chess club since its inception tell us
about that yeah so I think I was 16
years old when I met Rex and Jeanne and
we connected through our mutual love of
fine woodworking and shortly after we
met Jeanne called me and said hey could
you make a chess table for Rex
and I'm like well I've never made one
but yeah I'd be great so I'll make this
chess table and I made several more over
the years and then Jeanne calls me and
said hey we're starting a chess club in
st. Louis and I'm thinking a chess club
I mean wow okay this is interesting and
she said we need some nice chess tables
for the Borg room so okay well perfect
so we came up with a new design and I
got to build and build more over the
years and it's been a lot of fun for me
it's been a project that done probably
the most proud of what is it what an
amazing opportunity there's suddenly the
Chess Club springs up and how could you
have guessed that it would be the
capital of chess you know things now
almost the world yeah it's amazing it's
truly amazing I'm so honored to be part
of it
and you have your own company I
understand Cowan architectural design is
it
I would working woodworking yeah so my
father started the company in 1982 and
he was my dad had a rough childhood it
was born in Chicago lived there views of
home situation and for him he took a
high school woodworking class and and
woodworking was a therapy for him
something he could do with his hands and
then later there's nine kids in the
family so a place for all of us to work
and be brought up in
and so yeah it's been a neat business we
do a lot of work in hospitals and
airports restaurants all over the US and
now you're doing making this new chess
table for the best players on the planet
to come play on this by the way these
tables are awesome just wonderful we see
shots there if the player is playing
tell us about this design yeah so this
this design was a it's modeled after the
Cuban table of Bobby Fischer played on
in 66 loosely but it's got a twist of
today's technology in it so we've got
the electronic dtt boards in it there's
computer inside with the screen on the
end and they really are not too bright
but they really are an amazing table and
so we've got the but there were a lot of
there was a lot of thought in the design
process from the the spacing underneath
for for the legroom for a comfort
ability of the players with the leather
armrests and in the design alone I think
we've got about 150 hours recorded of
just design and prototyping for the
tables absolutely world class I know the
players love it and I know yasser is
begging for one all right you are not
only involved in the Chess Club and in
the making of it
you're also on the young professionals
board I understand tell yeah yeah yeah
so I was pushed by Loren Stewart several
years ago not to be part of this young
professionals board and it's a group of
young people I think it's about 18
members and under 40 years old and our
mission is to raise awareness for the
st. Louis chess campus and to and right
now we've got something that's new and
exciting I hope I can share this but
we're picking one school in the st.
Louis area
that it's not part of the educational
program and we're going to penetrate
that what does that mean so know it
sorry we're gonna we're going to teach
these kids I say we probably not me but
some of you were way smarter than me are
going to teach the kids to play
and given some opportunity wouldn't have
other expand your scope that's that's
fantastic yeah how can we learn more
about or can the folks learn more about
the work that you guys are doing is
there website yes how can they get
involved yeah on the chess club's
website
I think ends that are the join and give
section there's a spot about drug the
young professionals board and it's got
Alex Kurvers information on there cool
you play chess hang out for just any any
but now you got these beautiful chess
sets you must be playing playing some
chess on your sets I'm a far better
woodworker than a matches where modestly
said well you are a fine woodworker
indeed top of the line congratulations
thank you and how how many punches are
you getting today that's tough
thirty thirty it's like 15 people here
it means that everybody around has to do
that number of burpees first of all the
green tell it that on the tables what
material is that the green is it leather
is it cushion what is that
yeah so it's a leather cushion it was
very specifically designed for these
tables and the comfort ability of the
players look through several iterations
during the design process it's like a
soft yeah for the elbow so you can
really lean into the book into the table
yeah
now the obvious question is there if
there was anybody out there like myself
that would love to have one at home can
we order it
are they for sale they are for sales
like so yeah so shoot me an email and I
think it's posted on the screen but my
email is Nate at Kona woodworking calm
and yeah I would love to chat
all right great that's all I ask we do
have a lot of people tweeting in and
asking him like how do I get a table
like that
exactly I mean something for some of
them might you know they might be just
you know
wishful like their wish list for crazy
for something I think they might really
be serious about ordering that so I'll
remind them this is email well you know
it's like it's like a benz if you have
to ask the price you can't afford it
this guy's making the top of the line I
just did but you know what again and if
you don't you can get to the Chess Club
and they will know how to get it so
great work thank you very much happy
birthday what you think Nate Cohen
master woodworker making the finest of
the chess boards you can imagine for the
best players on the planet looking good
looking good Nate thank you very much
[Music]